ukrainians are fleeing to their
country's western borders to escape
russia's invasion
i want to eat now i want to sleep i want
to take a shower so far the majority
have headed to poland
once notorious for refusing to accept
syrian refugees the polish government is
welcoming ukrainians with open arms
the economist's correspondent pyotr
zalewski is in poland at one of the main
border crossings medica
and 80 kilometers away on the ukrainian
side is correspondent richard enzor
right now for everyone the polish border
means the eu and it means sanctuary a
week ago i was in kiev in the line of
fire and like a lot of other people i
got on a train and i dashed westward
away from the dropping bombs to try and
just put a little bit of distance
between myself and this outrageous war
that is unfolding already one million
people have crossed the border from
ukraine that's somewhere between two and
three percent of the population gone
this is the kind of exodus that we
haven't seen since the days of stalin
and hitler about half of the ukrainian
migrants who have left the country have
gone into poland it's a nato country and
it means that russian bombs are less
likely to be falling on that side of the
border than on this one
it's also a place with a lot of people
who are in the ukrainian diaspora people
who left after the first war in donbass
broke out in 2014 also
a lot of migrant workers from ukraine go
over to poland to pick the fruit to
drive the trucks and to do a lot of the
the labor that needs to be done there
and the years of that adding up have
mean that there's a lot of links there i
think possibly the most heartening part
of this is
seeing poles and ukrainians
living in poland
coming to the border to
volunteer and to help in in any way
possible you have
polish police you have ambulances you
have buses that are bringing people to
larger city centers near the border
they're bringing them to reception
centers to shelters and it seems like
you know the vast majority of people are
looked after relations between um poland
and ukraine and poles and ukrainians
have been
haunted you know for decades by
massacres perpetrated
during the second world war and also
forced resettlement in the aftermath of
the second world war um and to see those
these two nations you know um come
together like this
uh i think is also quite remarkable
the government has even said that it is
committed to providing shelter and
food to any ukrainian refugee and that's
quite a commitment to make given that
number according to the unhcr might
reach 4 million and it might reach 4
million quite soon this is of course
just the first part of what could become
an unimaginably big
exodus from ukraine so what we're seeing
now is this kind of first wave of people
who own cars
people who you know have connections
abroad people who feel like they can fit
just about most of their life into a
couple of suitcases and maybe a car
the second and subsequent waves are
going to be people who are poorer less
well connected and maybe less urban as
well less educated and of course older
so this is going to be something that
plays out over a very long period of
time if we don't manage to find a way
out of this war and of course as the
destruction grows
the amount of people
dreaming of a way
to europe is only going to grow with it
in 2015
16 there was also a great outpouring of
sympathy towards refugees particularly
from
syria but it didn't take long for
europe's borders to close and so that
moment of welcome that um
outpouring of sympathy was quite brief
and
i'm not sure how it'll play out with
respect to ukraine
there's a fear that uh places or
countries like poland
are next and that protein will not stop
um in ukraine and i think that you know
for the time being affects the level of
solidarity and sympathy shown towards
ukrainian
refugees
whether and how long that will last i
think is at this point still anyone's
guess
[Music]
thank you for watching um to read all
our coverage of the war in ukraine
please click on the link and don't
forget to subscribe